hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
diction of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer a question from one
of my newsletter readers hopes and who
wants to start a business but isn't sure
what businesses start and what it might
bice on how to get started so hopes and
thanks for the question I think it's a
lot there's a lot of people who go
through that same thing and trying to
figure out what business do I want to
start the most important thing I think
you could do is follow a business path
that you're really passionate about and
you think you can have a significant
impact on so if you look at all the
famous entrepreneurs and how they got
started they always talk about not the
money that they're going after but the
impact that they hope to have they have
a vision of the world that they want to
see and they can make that happen they
think they can help a lot of people so
providing value and helping people is at
the core of every successful business so
what is it that you're really excited
about you're really interested in and
you think you can really help people
with and then how can you build a
business around that so look at things
that you're passionate about look at
things that are your hobbies think about
things that you do for free anyway to
help other people and is there a way to
turn that into a business or not for me
for example I love helping entrepreneurs
and I do a lot of work helping
entrepreneurs and and I make these
videos helping entrepreneurs most of the
stuff that I do even these videos I
don't get paid to make these videos it's
I love helping entrepreneurs and and the
making these videos is something that I
love doing I look forward to every week
when I'm making these videos putting
them together now some of them i do get
paid for that might be sponsored but
most of the stuff that I do building up
the content you know is is free and I do
because I really love doing it and I've
been able to build a back-end business
model around it so what do you love to
do what would you do even if you weren't
getting paid for and is there a way to
turn that into a business opportunities
that's where I would start a lot of
entrepreneurs start the other way around
they look for just a way to make money
and if you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs they didn't start trying
to make money yes you need to make money
as part of business right you need to
put food on your table you need to pay
your bills you need to live the
lifestyle that
hopefully want to live and that comes
from having successful business where
you're making money but money isn't the
number one goal whenever money is your
number one goal you don't tend to see
those businesses do very well a lot of
them will shut down they may make enough
just to kind of support you know a
one-person shop but you don't see them
really taking off and becoming big
businesses so don't change the money
you'll find that you want to find a way
to make money from your passion but
follows to follow a path follow
something where you feel you can really
help people and provide a lot of value
and you are providing a lot of value
you'll start to make money the amount of
money you make will be in proportion to
how much value you provide to people and
how helpful you are so you want to build
it around something that you are super
excited about and can help a lot of
people with so hopefully that helps hope
ssin I love to hear you guys have to
think if you want to leave a comment on
the video if you want to share how you
started your business and why you
started your business it'd be great to
hear from you and if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up I always love
seeing those come in so thank you and
we'll see you in the next episode
you
you